it's the falling price of renewal
renewables the biggest threat to the
nuclear industry no you saw just now a
figures and let's be very careful with
this figures because it's true but let
me say half of atro because if you
combine all elements which you need to
establish a connection with a grid with
renewables if you need you need to pay
additionally for some backup facilities
if you combine all of this you will see
that nuclear is still minimum twice
cheaper than wind and minimum three
times cheapest and so on
and yet interestingly even you Rossum
are investing in wind turbines yes yes
we invest in convince Iran nuclear
that's why I'm qualified expert about it
and I see that investments in nuclear
are more interesting because it's still
cheaper now you in pretty fun fertile it
has to be said I think you got an order
book of something like 133 billion
dollars over the next decade
excluding Russia why are you succeeding
where the likes of some of your big
rivals lights of Arriva from France and
Westinghouse was Japanese and a
struggling no first of all our main
advantages as we cover the whole line of
all nuclear components means we have
everything at our disposal one company
starting from Mayank of uranium enough
to decommissioning of nuclear power
plant and honestly if we want to execute
some project we even don't need the
partners especially we work with
partners in different countries but we
have all resources inside and secondly
and it's very important point what we
are doing abroad it's not first of a
kind first we try to implement all new
projects on your designs all new
technical solution in our country and
only afterwards we go abroad because to
work in foreign countries indefinitely
much difficult and you work at home lot
of criticisms of the reactor technology
that's going to be deployed at Hinkley
Point C in this country what do you
thoughts on that I cannot comment in
Hinkley Point case because it's not our
story but what I personally believe that
what we have today as a level of modern
nuclear technology it's safe it's
reliable and can work minimum 60 years
after commissioning date can be
continued afterwards that's why I
believe that it still can be a very
significant part of energy balance which
in every country for nuclear
especially taking the account
venez Asian goal which cannot be
achieved without not there now we were
saying just now you selling to a lot of
countries of the man but other countries
particularly year a bit wary of you they
think they think you've got too many
close ties to the Kremlin how do you
react to that you know it everybody can
say that some government-owned company
is closed to something but I think it's
not a question where we why we win we
win because we provide to the customer
reliable solution referenced and cheap
all right Carioca model we have to leave
it there thank you for joining me you
could say thank you